we have reviewed a lot of woke
commercials on this channel
trying to figure out what products the
companies
are actually selling obviously what
they're really selling is just woke
politics but theoretically there's some
product in there somewhere
my record has not been great okay i'd
actually prefer not even to get into
what my record is here
it hasn't been terrific there is a
subspecies
of woke commercial that is really
proliferating these days
that would be the white guilt woke
commercials
we covered these a few months ago i now
want to try my hand at them again
because we're seeing them
everywhere while we have corporate
america telling us to be
less white which i think i'm doing a
pretty good job at actually as a
poor sicilian american we really have to
narrow in figure out where exactly this
is all coming from before we get started
this video is sponsored by
home title lock leader in home title
protection more from them later first
let's roll the tape
you love me you love me not
was that first guy white it was kind of
dubious
you love black culture but do you love
me
you love how i sound my voice these
beats
this flow not me though right
you love how i look my hair
this skin but me nah
we don't get to exist we're forced to
survive
kind of looks like they exist we still
fight
we still play while the world burns on
fields that ain't need
level man i don't like a hair product i
don't
all men are created equal
that's my favorite part you hate us so
deeply
but you're still so impressed why can't
you see
there's history in our skin there is not
history
in the skin i'm him he's me
she us
they talk about the hair specifically i
don't we gonna be us
[Music]
we gonna break bread okay
cool we're gonna defy gravity you're
probably not
you love my culture but do you love me
i love this boat culture i don't like
that culture at all
beats by dre ah man do i do i get any
points
because the the ears are next to the
hair
no so i don't know i probably don't get
any points for that
i guess they did keep saying like you
love my music and uh
something tells me i don't know just
judging by that narrative
i don't know that i will love that guy's
music i don't really love dr dre's music
i guess there are some exceptions
uh that's that's really weird that's a
really weird one
because i it hadn't occurred to me
until i watched that commercial that
there could be a difference between
existing and surviving did you he goes
we're not allowed
to exist we have to survive
well if i'm no metaphysician okay i'm no
philosopher but it seems to me
if you are surviving that presupposes
that you
have existed but that's what this is all
about it's just like words
you know it's words that don't mean
anything
together jumbled up but if you say it
you know in like a really cool
deep slow kind of voice little gravelly
over here
then then it sounds really really
profound
all right well yeah i don't get any
points for that let's try the next one
[Music]
racism is everywhere no it's not like
what we gotta keep pushing forward
i guess blm is pretty racist that's true
and they are everywhere now so
the truth is silence is not an option
actually it is
silence most times people are talking
silence
might be better
to come here
some of the injustice that we've been
seeing it's not okay
what injustice what what specifically
are you talking about
let us be perfectly clear black lives
matter wow brave
wow i haven't heard that except from
every corporation and politician and
university in hollywood and just
everyone who has any power in this
country
[Music]
the lm i don't know man like
yeah see i couldn't even like venture a
guess
i i was wondering if it was just kind of
like a psa or something like that
the nba think think about the rich irony
of the nba saying racism is everywhere
majority of nba players what what
race do would you say most sort of nba
players come from
are they irish are they tibetan
no in america black people are what like
12 of the population
is more than 12 of the nba black well is
it that's evidence of racial
disparity racism is everywhere in the
nba if you ask me
what a joke man what a what a woke joke
that is huh
you never thought that covid could cost
you your home right you probably thought
that was a joke
well it can cyber crime is up 75
by far the most serious cyber crime to
worry about is home title
theft this is something i didn't even
really know about until recently i was
hearing about it
cyber criminals foreign and domestic are
now
after our homes and it is easier than
you would think to get it
the title documents to our homes are
online now
the thief finds your home's title and
forges your signature on a quick claim
deed stating that you sold your home to
him
then he takes out loans on your home and
leaves you in debt
you won't know about this until late
payment or eviction notices arrive
insurance doesn't cover you and neither
do common identity theft programs
that is why i would strongly recommend
you protect your home
with home title lock the instant home
title lock detects someone tampering
with anyone's home title they can help
to shut it down
go to hometitlelock.com register your
address to see if you are already a
victim
then use codenoles canon wles to receive
30 free days of protection that is code
knowles at hometitlelock.com
hometitlelock.com
now that we feel protected let's return
to the white guilt
my producers have informed me that
there's nothing to guess
for these videos these were just videos
submitted by you
the viewers of great instances of white
guilt in promotional materials and i
just can't resist
with taking a look at them so let's roll
the tape
is your skin color holding you back no
are you tired of systemic prejudice
ruining your day
i'd like to tell you about a new
solution to racial inequality
white squad professional white advantage
services
y squad is a team of carefully selected
white representatives who act on behalf
of people of color
where your stand-ins for life's racially
unbalanced
situations like applying to college your
team members are standing there is that
probably that wouldn't be a great
service then you'd get a you'd have a
disadvantage
if you were to do
having legal troubles white squad will
appear in court for you
giving you the full benefits of being a
white person in the legal system
how do we do it we've assembled a team
of reassuring white people
each with unique areas of effectiveness
we pre-screen
all of our employees to ensure their
names and appearances provide maximum
benefits to you
that's why our services come with a 100
advantage guarantee i had good grades
but i couldn't get a scholarship then i
called white squad and i was decorating
my dorm room in no time then i called
white squad and was actually
disadvantaged by law in applying to
college yeah wow great
great idea white squad
professional white advantage services
what
who is putting this out what channel is
this on that's just some some commercial
out there
white squad is a part of look different
which is mtv's
multi-year campaign that works to shed
light and combat bias based on race
gender and sexual orientation apparently
this according to the description from
the video
it's funny i guess because
it's totally divorced from reality the
video is evidence itself that it's
divorced from reality
because there's only one racial group
that it is publicly and socially
acceptable
to deride and denigrate and mock and
that's white people
and it's not only socially acceptable
it's actually encouraged by the dominant
culture
it's encouraged by mtv one of the
strongest arguments against the
point of this video is that you're
allowed to make this video whereas if
you were to make that video about black
people or
mexicans or whatever any other racial
group
you would be you would have your life
ruined you would be ostracized from
society you'd lose your job you'd lose
you'd be de-platformed you couldn't do
it so just a total fantasy
i can't believe because the whole time
the thing that keeps coming back in your
mind is
there is a one law in this country that
does discriminate
and on the basis of race and give people
advantage and other people disadvantage
that law is called affirmative action it
gives advantage to black people
and hispanics and some other racial
groups and it disadvantages whites and
asians
and they actually used that example they
said oh yeah you know it's really hard
to get a good college scholarship and
get but you know then i pretended to be
white
in reality it's exactly the opposite
from that but that's why
that's why you find it on television
right and because it it is a fantasy
and the reality of it of course uh
nobody would want to talk about
except for crazy people who are probably
gonna get de-platformed on youtube if
you in any way
question this sort of dominant liberal
narrative all right next one this looks
like it comes from
cartoon network about black
history let's roll it
all right class can anyone tell me who
invented the light bulb
that's not entirely true it isn't the
light bulb could more rightfully be
attributed to lewis latimer the black
inventor behind the filament
inside the ball that's just not
[Music]
well so now you know
wait is that it hold on we're not going
to mention
why he invented the filament to create a
better standard of living for people who
had only just been freed from slavery
are we going to ask why kids are
apparently learning about thomas edison
and not learning about louis latimer
these textbooks are
because thomas edison invented the light
bulb louis latimer sort of
black classical musicians black cowboys
black fighter pilot
where are they i worry about you humans
because you only live what about 100
years
you rely on these stories to know your
own history
thanks to systemic racism most of your
storytellers is this seriously on
cartoon network
which leaves you with an incomplete
picture ask yourself is your learning
history
who's telling the story i mean this is
presenting reality in as much as
it's an angry liberal white lady yelling
at us all i think the scolding is
certainly uh has to do with reality but
what she's saying just isn't true
thomas edison invented the light bulb
and i remember
joe biden i think brought this up he
said he said hey
hey corn pop listen mr malarkey
uh thomas edison a white guy he didn't
invent the light bulb it was a black guy
in lewis latimer it's just not not true
reuters actually even admitted this
reuters had a fact check said that louis
latimer invented a longer-lasting
filament for light bulbs so he kind of
improved upon the light bulb
but he did not invent the light bulb
ronald reagan had this line he said it's
it's not
so much that our liberal friends are
ignorant it's not what they
don't know it's that they know so many
things that aren't so
this angry cartoon lib lady who probably
has one of those pink hats and marches
around on weekends
she is so certain that the people who
made this cartoon are so
certain of what they're saying but it
just isn't true and it
what they're doing though is a brilliant
strategy i mean we can make fun of it
all we want
but it's brilliant because the reason
the left always goes after
education why they've taken such a keen
interest in education and now in
sort of children's books and children
you know dr seuss
and children's cartoons is because if
you can shape impressionable minds
when they're still being molded those
changes have a far greater chance of
sticking
than if you were to present this
argument if if they presented this
argument
on on some adult network not like an
adult not like xxx but like on a network
for adults
it wouldn't work because you'd say oh
wait thomas thomas edison didn't invent
the light bulb hold on let me oh yeah
that's just not true okay never mind
but kids aren't gonna do that so they're
just gonna believe this stuff all right
let's finish out the tape
was this modified to make white readers
comfortable are major details being left
out that would credit people of color
and center their point of view
honestly i should have asked for script
approval before agreeing to do this
we'll do some rewrites i'm sorry we
didn't know well
so now you know i swear
was that robin deangelo i think that
actually was i'm not even sure this was
a cartoon i think that just was robin
d'angelo the bit of truth that we can
really
glean from this that we should all think
about is do you want to be like a normal
adjusted human being who's grateful to
people like uh
thomas edison who invented the light
bulb and latimer who improved it
and you know sort of like one another
and like our country and be grateful for
stuff
or do you want to be just an angry
scolding
bitter white liberal lady cartoon
which do you want to because those are
two those that's the political divide
right there are you on that ladies team
or are you with the rest of us who are
laughing at it and
trying to set the record straight be
sure to post some other videos if you
find any that are that are pushing this
kind of stuff
the white guild specifically or woke is
more broadly post in the comments
section we will look forward
to reviewing them next time
[Music]
[Music]